let's do some example problems here so
we have the perimeter of each of the
outer triangles is 30. so for example if
i took the sum of this side
this side
and that side i will get 30 and that's
true of all of these outer triangles
these five outer triangles they then
tell us that the perimeter of f g h i j
so f g h i j the perimeter of this
pentagon right over here is 50. so if i
add up that side plus that side plus
that side plus that side plus that side
i get 50. and then they say what is the
perimeter of the star
so the perimeter of the star is really
the outsides if you take the bases away
of each of these triangles so it's this
side let me do this in a new color
actually so the perimeter of the
triangle i'll do an orange it's going to
be this
plus that
plus that plus that i think you get the
idea plus that
plus that plus that plus that so the
perimeter of the of the star so let me
call this the perimeter
perimeter
of the star
is going to be equal to the perimeter of
the five triangles is equal to
perimeter
of
five outer triangles
i'll just call them five triangles like
this
minus their bases
right if i take the perimeter of all of
these guys if i added it up
the part that shouldn't be part of the
perimeter of the star should would be
this part that part that part that part
that part and that part those aren't the
part those aren't part of the perimeter
of the star so should be the perimeter
of the five triangles minus
the length of their bases
length
of their five bases
so what's the perimeter of the five
triangles well the perimeter of each of
them is 30 so the perimeter of five of
them is going to be 5 times 30 which is
now we want to subtract out the lengths
of their five bases now the lengths of
their five bases if we add them up is
the exact perimeter of this inner
pentagon right over here so this inner
pentagon has a perimeter of 50 that is
the sum of the five bases so that right
over here is 50. so the perimeter of the
star is going to be 150 minus 50 or
or 100. all we did is took the perimeter
of all the triangles subtracted out
these bases which was the perimeter of
the inner pentagon and and we're done
now let's do the next problem
what is the area of this this
quadrilateral something that has four
sides of abcd and this is a little bit
we haven't seen a figure quite like this
just yet it on the right hand side it
looks like a rectangle on the left-hand
side looks like a triangle this is
actually a trapezoid but we can actually
as you could imagine the way we figured
out the area of several triangles is
splitting it up into into pieces that we
can recognize and the most obvious thing
to do here is start at a and then just
drop a rock drop an altitude right over
here and so this line right over here is
going to hit at 90 degrees and we could
call this point e
and what's interesting here is now we
can split this up into something that we
recognize a rectangle and a right
triangle but you might say wait sal how
do we figure out how do we figure out
what these you know we have this side
and that side so we can figure out the
area of this rectangle pretty
straightforwardly but how would we how
do we figure out the area of this
triangle
well if this side is 6 then that means
that this that e c is also going to be
6. if a b is 6 notice we have a
rectangle right over here opposite sides
of a rectangle are equal so if a b
a b equals 6
implies that ec is equal to 6.
ec is equal to 6. so ec is equal to 6
and if ec is equal to 6 then that tells
us that de is going to be 3
d e is going to be 3. this distance
right over here is going to be 3 and we
know that because if this is 6 this has
to be something that we add to 6 to get
9. 9 was the length of this entire of
the entire base of this figure right
over here 9 was this entire distance so
nine minus six gives us the three and
now we have all the information that we
need to figure out the area
the area of this part right over here
this rectangle is just going to be six
times seven so it's going to be equal to
plus the area of this triangle right
over here
over here and that's one half base times
height one half the base over here is
three
one half times three and the height over
here
is once again it's going to be 7. this
is a rectangle opposite sides are equal
so if this is 7 then this is also going
to be 7. one-half times 3 times 7. so
it's going to be 42 let's see 3 times 7
is 21 21 divided by 2 is 10.5
10.5 so this is going to be equal to
52.5
52.5 is the area of this entire figure
let's do one more
so here i have a bizarre looking a
bizarre looking
shape and we need to figure out its
perimeter and at first it seems very
daunting because they've only given us
this side and this side and they've also
only given us
this side right over here and one thing
that we are allowed to assume in this
and you don't always have to make you
can't always make that assumption and i
just didn't draw it here ahead of time
just because it would have really
crowded out this this diagram is that
all of the angles in this diagram are
right angle so i could have drawn a
right angle here right angle here right
angle there right angle there but as you
can see it kind of makes things a little
bit it makes things a little bit messy
but how do we figure out the perimeter
if we don't know these little distances
here and the secret here is to kind of
shift the sides because all we want to
care about is the sum of the side so
what i'm going to do is a little
exercise in shifting the sides
so this side right over here i'm going
to shift it and put it right up there
then this side right over here
this length right over here i'm going to
shift it and put it right over there
then let me keep using different colors
then this side right over here i'm going
to shift it and put it right up here
then finally i'm going to have
this side right over here i can shift it
and put it right over there and i think
you see what's going on now now all of
these sides combined are going to be the
same as this side where i'm kind of
building
even though this thing wasn't a
rectangle it's it's its perimeter is
going to be a little bit interesting
although we have to think about this 2
right over here now let's think about
all of these sides that are going up and
down so this side i can shift it all the
way to the right and go right over here
let me make it clear this orange side
goes all the way to the end right that's
just the exact same orange side now this
white side i can shift all the way to
the right over there
then this
this green side i can shift
right over
there
and then i have and then i can shift and
then i can shift this actually let me
not shift that green side yet let me
just leave that green side so i haven't
i haven't done anything yet let me be
clear i haven't done anything yet with
that and that i haven't shifted them
over and let me take this side right
over here and shift it over so let me
take this entire thing
and shift it over there
and shift it over there so before i
count these two pieces right over here
and we know that they each have length
two these are all 90 degree angles so
this has length two this has length two
before i count those two pieces i've
shifted everything else so i was able to
form a rectangle so at least just
counting everything else i have seven
plus six let me say seven plus six
all of these combined are also going to
be seven
plus seven and then all of these
characters combined are also going to be
six
plus six and then finally i have this
two right here that i haven't counted
before this two
plus this 2
plus this 2 and then we have our
perimeter so what does this give us 7
plus 6 is 13 plus 7 is 20 plus 6 is 26
plus 4 more is equal to 30 and we're
done